LAURA:  A NEW BOOK ON THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY IS UNLIKE ANYTHING
YOU HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
THIS WAS WRITTEN A FEW DAYS AGO
IN THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER,
ELECTION ON NOTHING LESS THAN
DESTROYING THE CREDIBILITY OF
THE NEWS MEDIA AND THE MEDIA ARE
DETERMINED TO DO THE SAME WITH
HIM WITH ONLY ONE SIDE ACHIEVING
VICTORY WITH THE PRESS FALLING
INTO THE PRESIDENT'S TRAP AND
ARE DELIGHTED TO WELCOME THE
RIDER OF THAT PIECE AND THE
THE WAR ON THE TRUTH.
AND LET YOUR PIECE AND THE
HOLLYWOOD REPORTER AND FOUND
THIS ELEMENT FROM JOHN MARTIN,
JONATHAN MARTIN FROM THE NEW
WEEKS BEFORE THE CONVENTION A
RNC STAFF MEMBER CALLED HIM TO
CHALLENGE HIS STORY AND HE SHOT
BACK SAYING YOU ARE A RACIST AND
SUPPORTING HIM YOU ARE ALL
CULPABLE WAS SPICER CALLED THE
TIMES EDITOR AND UNLOADED ABOUT
MARTIN'S BEHAVIOR AT HALF AN
HOUR LATER MARTIN CALLED SPICER
AND SAYS HOW DARE YOU COULD GO
BEHIND GO BEHIND MY BACK.
EXCUSE ME, SPICER REPLIED, YOU
CALL ONE OF MY PEOPLE AND SAY
JONATHAN MARTIN IS ONE OF THE
TOP RIDERS AT THE NEW YORK
T IMES.
>> HE IS A GOOD REPORTER BUT
HAVE FOUR SOURCES INCLUDING THAT
RNC STAFFER WHO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION
>> OBVIOUSLY, MARTIN IS
DISPUTING IT SINCE IT BECAME
OUT.
SPICER WENT ON THE RADIO SHOW
AND CONFIRMED ON RECORD THAT MY
ACCOUNT IS ACCURATE.
>> NOT ONLY SUCH AN IMPORTANT
REPORTER FOR THE THE NEW YORK
TIMES THAT HIS ACCOUNTS OF THE
CAMPAIGN ARE THEN REPEATED AND
TAKEN BY OTHER REPORTERS.
WHEN HE IS REPORTING ON A
YOU MUST HAVE A DESIRE TO REMOVE
A RACIST AND FASCIST FROM THE
OFFICE.
THE FOLLOWING IS THERE ARE A LOT
OF LEGITIMATE STORIES ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND CREATES HIS OWN
DISTRACTIONS BUT TOO MANY PEOPLE
AND JOURNALISTS THINK IT IS
THERE JOB TO SAVE THE COUNTRY
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
>> LAURA: THAT IS CRUSADING.
TAKE THE CHART BUT IS
DISCONCERTING AND THE PUBLIC
VIEW OF THE PRESS.
WHERE IS IT TODAY FROM 10 YEARS
AGO, HAS A DECLINED?
THE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THIS
PRESIDENT, IT BIG CHUNK OF THE
COUNTRIES.
>> LAURA: 45% NOW.
>> IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
ATTACKS THEM, THEY TREAT THEM
WITH DISDAIN.
NEGATIVE COVERAGE OF DONALD
TRUMP, CAMPAIGN AND PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY HELPED HIM BECAUSE HE
CONTROLS THE NEWS AGENDA AND
STRIKES A NERVE WITH THE SUPPORE
STRIKES A NERVE WITH THE SUPPORS
>> YESTERDAY WHEN HE LEFT FOR
DAVOS, SAYING THE SOMETHING
SAID, DO YOU KNOW IF HILLARY
TESTIFIED UNDER OATH?
THAT SMART?
>> IT IS SMART HERE IS HIS OWN
SPOKESMAN BUT IS NOT ALWAYS
SMART TO ATTACK JOURNALISTS,
INDIVIDUALLY AND CREATES